[Music]
time now for what to watch and i know
that that music is referring to your
first story but i got a call back to
friday
all right that story on the grinch
remember the teenager
a viewer named marissa boras was
watching that and she said just like the
grinch my heart grows three sizes
every morning
very nice marissa thank you very much i
my
my heart does grow three size too big
when i get those kind of intros
that's nice thank you very much and
you're right tony that intro music is
for the story
that we think you'll be talking about
today we are paying tribute
to actor david lander known for playing
squiggy
on the hit 70s sitcom laverne in shirley
there is no reason on earth why prince
charming cannot walk through
our front door hello
i still wear a leather jacket like that
and i still say hello
just like swiggy lander died friday in
los angeles his wife says
he battled multiple sclerosis for half
his life lander was comedy gold when
paired alongside his real life friend
michael mckeon who played
lenny they were laverne and shirley's
upstairs neighbors if you recall
lander appeared in 120 movies and tv
series david lander
was 73 years old yeah uh michael
video makes you laugh it really does and
they would come in and whenever
women would walk by i know it's probably
not normal now but they would do their
little oh
yeah yeah yeah i just don't realize it
but he and mccain
had actually been classmates at carnegie
mellon university yes and developed
those characters there that's right
and michael mckeon tweeted a very very
beautiful photo of the two of them when
they were very young men who was really
sad
we were missing will be uh all right
last night's mtv movie and tv awards had
an especially
memorable moment the late chadwick
boseman was honored by his fellow marvel
marvel stars don cheadle and robert
downey jr
the way he lived his life united people
behind a higher purpose
and that will be his legacy and he
wasn't just a hero on screen
his list of selfless and inspirational
acts indeed
it's too long to recount here he was the
most heroic when just being chat
that's when he was bigger than anyone he
played on screen
the two actors spoke as they honored
bozeman with the hero for the ages award
the black panther actor died in august
at the age of 43 after a private
four-year battle with colon cancer and
guys i always think that
i i had no idea that he was going
through this cancer
very few people did and he was playing a
that's not a superhero
in real life yeah i mean vlad it just
shows you the more you know
i admired him of course before he died
but the more you hear about
how he lived his life and what he was
going through your admiration room just
grows and grows and grows
what do you hear about him what a true
class act in a hero
and not just the superheroes he played
the big luminaries
that he portrayed on the screen like
james brown he actually
got james brown's move down pat it was
really great that film
i love it we'll miss him so sad um
all right this is cool sports
illustrated has named the activist
athlete as sports person of the year
and recognize not one but five
individuals
super bowl mvp patrick mahomes was
chosen for
using his platform to push a league to
recognize the black lives matter
movement
tennis champ naomi osaka got everyone
talking for using her voice
in the fight against social injustice
wnba star brianna stewart
also spoke loudly against racism and for
women's equality
kansas city chiefs lineman lauren
duvernay tardif
who is also a doctor and opted out
of the 2020 nfl season to help fight the
coronavirus
in a hospital and lebron james who led
the lakers to the nba title was
recognized for working around the clock
to end
voter suppression yeah you knew lebron
was going to be on that list but they
were all very good choices yeah that's a
really impressive list
it is very cool and there's a great
photo of naomi osaka and
during the u.s open she wore a mask with
the names of people like
lando castillo and she would change
every day every day exactly it's very
cool
all right here's a little pep talk we
can use on a monday
this is tanya babich she's a local tv
news anchor in chicago
and she had a lesson for one of her
daughters who was afraid to wear her
glasses
she was worried what her classmates
would think so mom
proudly put on her own specs and relayed
this message
on a gesture of solidarity i've been
wearing mine all week to make this point
whatever people say or think about you
is none of your business
just be yourself authentically and
unapologetically
the rest will work itself out right on
tanya
the rest of the news crew put on their
glasses too in a show of solidarity
with glasses nothing not at all
164 million americans including me
you anthony gayle you i don't know if i
have a pair uh indeed
oh you do i used to wear them on tv for
years yeah you need a photo another guy
on tv so i stopped doing it it wasn't
this guy
that would be a problem glad when i was
little there was a saying you probably
remembered anthony do you remember tony
boys don't make passes at girls that
wear glasses you remember that
that's do you have you heard of that i
have heard of that i think that's not
true though that's
not true i can speak for myself that
ain't true
but i love the mom doing that for her
daughter what a great very cool
and everyone else on the team pitching
in wearing their glasses it really was
that was a wonderful parental move yes